When amorous, a male Costa’s hummingbird
puffs out his purple throat feathers.
He woos his intended mate by zipping from
side to side in his signature “shuttle dance”
showing off his brilliant plumage.
Of course, not every male shines as brightly
as the next.
But according to new research, dull males
can make themselves appear brighter by orienting
toward the sun as they display.
Scientists filmed male hummingbirds dancing
in front of caged females, and mapped out
their angles relative to the sun and the female
during their routines.
Then, they plucked a few feathers from each
performer and used those to re-enact the male’s dance.
They used the same angles with respect to the sun
in locations that mimicked the original lighting.
As the feathers moved through the dance routines,
the scientists snapped photos with a camera
specially programmed to capture colors
the way a bird sees them.
It turns out, the males that appeared brightest
to females weren’t necessarily the ones
with the brightest plumage.
Instead, the most vibrant males were those
who directly faced the sun as they danced.
These eye-catching dancers had more light
bouncing off of their iridescent feathers,
making their color pop compared to those who
had faced away.
The finding shows one way that animals can
manipulate their appearance by altering how
they interact with the environment.
So, if you’re a male Costa’s hummingbird,
you don’t need to be a
natural beauty to impress the ladies.
The right lighting can go a long way.